traveling and touring is like even  though it looked fun that's just hard  it's super hard work so  just just to keep that momentum and that  energy up take a lot of work so if  you're not all the way invested that's  gonna say when you guys were all on tour  together did you did was that like  because i feel like when you tour with  someone you're kind of living with them  right exactly so when that happens  living with people you get to see like  like this might not work exactly that's  like that's like oh yeah all y'all broke  [ __ ] be fighting with your mama  because you living with people man it's  like yeah that's not working do you  think that that was kind of like a eye  opener for you when you guys toured like  okay maybe we don't get along like we  thought we did or yeah for sure that was  definitely  it had to be like one of the a big  factor